so the Man of Steel comes out this
summer a lot of people are worried a lot
of fans of Superman are really really
worried because there has been banter
about it being darker grittier edgier
these are not words you usually want to
have associated with Superman they don't
fit
but for this little meeting of the
council I want to say how a darker
grittier Superman might actually work to
hear all the fans of Superman
complaining now and what they say they
want you know the Superman who is pure
and he is good and well you know what
you got that movie already was called
Superman Returns a general reaction was
mmm so you don't get to complain now
about how oh don't make him darn gritty
you got your pure good clean Superman
and you pissed and moaned about it so
shut up you don't know what you want
that's it I do believe you can't make
this guy dark and gritty because if you
do it it's not honoring the character
and you're doing somebody else you might
as well have just made a movie out of a
different superhero cuz Superman and
this has always kind of been the issue
with him he is what we are aspiring to
not just in terms of physical strength
but his moral fortitude that's kind of a
problem it makes him a little bit boring
me he's not tormented he's certainly not
Batman he's not even spider-man for that
matter
when it comes to that sort of emotional
depth he's pretty straightforward that's
who he is I mean fundamentally that is
what he needs to be so to start grit
eing that up and trying to make him edgy
or trying to give him I don't know
emotional scars make him a loose cannon
it just doesn't think you can't do that
but you can gritty up the world you
could just make the world he is existing
in more in line with the real world you
go back and look at the old Superman
and not only is Superman hearing good
the world he inhabits is pretty postcard
you know you've got the bad aspects
you've got your Lex Luthor's or whatever
but by and large people are Oh Superman
oh there it they're in awe of him he
doesn't even really have to earn it all
that much let's drop that how would
people in the real world really react
truly to a being that came out of
nowhere and could fly at supersonic
speeds and could punch you so your head
caved in how would we react to that
we would be scared as hell that that
might even be how they're going there
have been more than a few publicity
shots of Superman in handcuffs that to
me kind of hints that maybe they're
going for not making him more gritty but
making the environment he's he's set in
more gritty and that might work again
it's possible that there isn't that
isn't what they're doing and they're
just gonna give him excessive amount of
daddy issues and all this other bull
crap but we won't know till it comes out
and it could work I could be wrong it's
happening once before so on that note
Council is adjourned